I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Are you ready for a baby shower? I sure am.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。你准备好迎接一个婴儿淋浴派对了吗？我当然准备好了。
This is Jan's baby shower today. At a company she no longer works at, with a man she no longer dates and is not the father of her baby, it's going to be a huge success. Oh, yeah. Yeah. All the elements are there. Right? Yes.
今天是简的婴儿淋浴派对。在一个她已经不再工作的公司里，和一个她不再约会且不是她孩子父亲的男人一起，这绝对会是一个巨大的成功。哦，是的。是的。所有要素都齐了。对吧？是的。
People she doesn't really like are throwing her a baby shower. And they don't like her. It's going to be great. It's season five, episode four. This episode was written by Erin Shore and directed by Greg Daniels. I have a summary. Let's do it. Michael and the party planning committee, still headed by Phyllis, throw a baby shower
她并不怎么喜欢的人正在为她举办婴儿淋浴派对。而他们也不喜欢她。这绝对会很棒。这是第五季第四集。这一集由埃林·肖尔编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯导演。我有一个总结。我们开始吧。迈克尔和派对策划委员会，依然由菲利斯领导，举办了一场婴儿淋浴派对
for Jan. But they are unaware that she has already given birth to her daughter Astrid. Jan's presence in The Office causes Michael to be rude to Holly and Dwight spends the day putting Jan's luxury stroller to the test. Meanwhile, Jim and Pam feel the effects of their long-distance relationship. Oh, that was hard to watch. They were out of sync. They were.
为了简。但他们并不知道她已经生下了女儿阿斯特丽德。简在办公室的出现导致迈克尔对霍莉态度粗鲁，而德怀特则花了一整天时间测试简的豪华婴儿车。与此同时，吉姆和帕姆感受到了异地恋带来的影响。哦，那一幕真难看。他们当时不在同一个频道的。确实是的。
You don't like to see that? No, I don't. Fast fact number one, new writer alert. Erin Shore joined the writing staff this year in season five. Erin had been a writer on Everybody Loves Raymond, which is one of my favorite sitcoms of all time. It is such a great ensemble sitcom. Do you know that one where Marie goes to art class and she makes the sculpture?
你不想看到那一幕？不，我不想。趣事一号，新编剧警报。埃林·肖尔今年加入了第五季的编剧团队。埃林曾是《人人都爱雷蒙德》的编剧，那是我有史以来最喜欢的情景喜剧之一。那真是一部非常棒的群戏情景喜剧。你知道那一集吗，玛丽去上艺术课，然后她做了一个雕塑？
And then guys, look it up. She makes a sculpture and she's so proud and she unveils it and it looks like a vagina. But she doesn't know, but everybody else is like, Marie, what inspired you to make this piece? Oh my gosh. It's so good. Her character was so good. So anyway, I was very excited to have Erin join the writing staff because then I could
然后伙计们，去查查看。她做了一个雕塑，她感到非常骄傲，然后她揭幕了它，结果它看起来像个阴道。但她自己不知道，而其他所有人都说，玛丽，是什么灵感让你创作了这件作品？哦天哪。太棒了。她的角色太棒了。所以无论如何，我很高兴埃林能加入编剧团队，因为这样我就可以
ask him tons of questions about Everybody Loves Raymond. And you did. I did. You chatted him up a lot about it. Well, we have some news. Angela, do you want to share? I do. So I reached out to Erin.
问他一大堆关于《人人都爱雷蒙德》的问题。而你也确实问了。我问了。你跟他聊了很多关于这方面的事。好吧，我们有个好消息。安吉拉，你想分享一下吗？我想。所以我联系了埃林。
We had been trying to get ahold of him. You slid into his DMs. I did. He was like, I don't even know. Do I have DMs? I'm like, yes. But I found an old email and we got in touch and it was so fun to talk to him. He's a huge fan of the podcast.
我们之前一直试图联系他。你私信了他。我确实这么做了。他说，我甚至不知道。我还有私信功能吗？我说，有的。但我找到了一个旧邮箱，我们联系上了，和他聊真的太有趣了。他是这个播客的超级粉丝。
Jenna, he told me that he listens to the podcast in the evenings and then sometimes when he drifts off to sleep, he dreams like that he's in the podcast with us. Oh my goodness. Is that a good dream or a nightmare? I don't know. I hope it's a good thing. I hope so. Erin had lots of great stuff to share.
珍娜，他告诉我他晚上会听这个播客，有时候当他迷迷糊糊快要睡着时，他会梦见自己和我们一起在这个播客里。哦天哪。那是好梦还是噩梦？我不知道。我希望是件好事。我希望如此。埃林有好多好料可以分享。
We're going to hit him up quite a bit. We have Erin now. We have James and also Randy Cordray. Yes. When Angela told me that she got ahold of Erin, I know you were going to ask him about the office, but I had an Everybody Loves Raymond question. Still, this poor man, I cornered him on set and now you're calling him on the phone and my question is still about Everybody Loves Raymond.
我们要经常找他聊聊。我们现在有埃林了。我们有詹姆斯，还有兰迪·科德雷。是的。当安吉拉告诉我她联系到埃林时，我知道你会问他关于办公室的事，但我有一个关于《人人都爱雷蒙德》的问题。话说回来，这个可怜的人，我曾在片场把他逼到角落，现在你又给他打电话，而我的问题居然还是关于《人人都爱雷蒙德》的。
But here's the thing. I remember that there was this episode that was based on a story from his real life, but they couldn't remember all the details. It's the episode. It's called 10th Anniversary and Ray and Deborah are celebrating their 10th anniversary and they want to watch their wedding tape and they get it out and they put it in the VCR. They press play and Ray has recorded a football game over their wedding tape. And I remember that there is some story where I think Erin recorded over his wedding tape
但问题是。我记得有一集是根据他真实生活中的一个故事改编的，但他们记不清所有细节了。就是那一集。它叫《第十周年》，雷和黛布拉正在庆祝他们的第十周年结婚纪念日，他们想看他们的婚礼录像带，然后他们拿出来放进录像机里。他们按下播放键，结果雷在他们的婚礼录像带上录了一场橄榄球比赛。我记得有个故事，好像是埃林录掉了他的婚礼录像带
with his wife. That is true. I knew it. That is true. So this is what happened. Okay. So Erin was a fan of Everybody Loves Raymond. It was a show he wanted to meet on.
和他妻子。那是真的。我就知道。那是真的。事情是这样的。好吧。所以埃林是《人人都爱雷蒙德》的粉丝。那是他很想去面试的节目。
So he thought, oh, I'll record a few episodes, watch them, really study the show. So when I go in and meet, you know, I have all this information. So he popped in a VHS guys. This dates us all a little bit and he hit record and it was his wedding video. Yeah. And back then you guys, it's not like you have multiple copies. Like you get your wedding video tape and that's it. Yeah.
所以他想，哦，我录几集，看看，好好研究一下这个节目。这样当我进去面试时，你知道的，我就掌握了所有这些信息。于是他放进了一盘录像带，伙计们。这暴露了我们的年龄，他按下了录像键，结果那是他的婚礼录像。是的。而在那个年代，伙计们，不像现在有多个备份。就像你拿到你的婚礼录像带，那就是全部了。是的。
Yeah. His wife was really upset. Oh no. And he went in to meet on Everybody Loves Raymond and he told that story. He was like, I taped over my wedding video to watch Everybody Loves Raymond. So my wife is really mad. You got to give me this job and he got the job. And then that story made it into an episode.
是的。他妻子非常沮丧。哦不。然后他去面试《人人都爱雷蒙德》时，他讲了那个故事。他说，我录掉了我的婚礼录像来重温《人人都爱雷蒙德》。所以我的妻子非常生气。你们得给我这份工作，然后他得到了这份工作。接着那个故事就被写进了一集节目里。
Yes. Oh, I love it. A lot of Erin's life ends up in scripts, you guys. There's a few episodes coming up that his actual life inspired things that Michael does and I can't wait to share those with you. I'm so glad we're in touch with him. I know. Fast fact number two, Angela, we shot this episode in August of 2008 and since we brought
是的。哦，我太喜欢了。埃林生活中的许多经历最终都变成了剧本，伙计们。接下来有几集的内容，他的现实生活启发了迈克尔的所作所为，我迫不及待地想跟你们分享。我很高兴我们和他保持着联系。我知道。趣事二号，安吉拉，我们是在2008年8月拍摄这一集的，既然我们之前已经提过了
it up before, I thought it was worth mentioning that this same month, Steve Carell won his second surfboard at the 2018 Choice Awards for TV comedy actor. Steve, where did you put your surfboards? Back to Pack's surfboard. Wow. When we have him on the podcast, is it going to be weird if we ask him where his surfboards are? It depends where you put them.
我觉着值得一提的是，正是在同一个月，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在2008年选择奖上赢得了他的第二个冲浪板奖，奖项是电视喜剧男演员。史蒂夫，你把你的冲浪板放哪儿了？回到了帕克的冲浪板那儿。哇。当我们邀请他来上播客时，如果我们问他冲浪板放哪儿了，会不会很奇怪？这取决于你把它们放在哪里了。
It's going to be such a weird question. Well also this same year, the movie Juno won Best Comedy Movie and Rainn Wilson was in that. Also this same year, we won a SAG Award. Yes. This was like the awards and the surfboards were coming in now. Yeah. Right?
这会是一个多么奇怪的问题啊。哦，还有在同一年，电影《朱诺》赢得了最佳喜剧电影奖，雷恩·威尔逊也参演了。同样在这一年，我们赢得了美国演员工会奖。是的。这就是各种奖项和冲浪板接踵而至的时候。是的。对吧？
It was really cool and I remember at the 2008 SAG Awards, we were sitting at the table and everybody was like, who's going to give the speech if we win and we all assumed it would be Steve. Like Steve will give the speech and Steve said, guys, this is an ensemble. I don't want to always speak for the cast. That doesn't feel right to me. This is an ensemble award. I think someone else should speak.
真的很酷，我记得在2008年的美国演员工会奖上，我们坐在桌子旁，每个人都在说，如果我们赢了，谁来发表获奖感言呢，我们都以为会是史蒂夫。就像史蒂夫会发表感言一样，而史蒂夫说，伙计们，这是一个集体奖项。我不想总是代表演员阵容发言。这让我觉得不对劲。这是一个集体奖项。我认为应该由别人来发言。
I mean, first of all, amazing, right? He's so sweet. Awesome. And so then Rainn said, I think Jenna should do it and I feel like none of us really thought we were going to win because we'd won the year before and I said, oh, okay, yeah, sure, I'll do it and then we won and I had to give a speech at an award show. And you did such a great job. You were so articulate and well-spoken.
我的意思是，首先，太棒了吧？他太贴心了。太棒了。然后雷恩说，我觉得应该让珍娜来。我觉得我们当时谁也没想到我们会赢，因为我们前一年刚赢过，我说，哦，好吧，行吧，我来。然后我们赢了，我不得不在一个颁奖典礼上发表获奖感言。而你表现得太棒了。你那么口齿伶俐，谈吐优雅。
I was in awe because we didn't think we were going to win. No. It was a total surprise. I mean, we won and I'm like walking to the stage and I'm like, oh my God. Well, I know you guys are tired of me talking about being pregnant, but I was pregnant at that award show and it's a very odd thing to be super huge and pregnant at an award show. But you did such a great job. Thank you.
我当时惊呆了，因为我们根本没料到会赢。没有。这完全是个惊喜。我是说，我们赢了，我一边走向舞台一边想，哦我的天呐。好吧，我知道你们可能听腻了我谈论怀孕的事，但我在那个颁奖典礼时确实怀孕了，在一个颁奖典礼上挺着个超级大的孕肚是一件非常奇妙的事情。但你真的表现得太棒了。谢谢。
I ended up kind of going down a rabbit hole of all the like cool things that happened for our show in 2008. It was a good year. It was a good year. James Carey sent me the call sheet for this episode. James Apedia. And on the call sheet, it said, there is a screening of Rainn Wilson's new movie, The Rocker at Universal CityWalk for the cast and crew.
我最后差不多陷入了一个关于我们节目在2008年发生的所有酷事的深度思考中。那是个好年份。那是个好年份。詹姆斯·凯瑞给我发了这一集的通告单。詹姆士·阿佩迪亚。而在通告单上写着，在环球影城步行街为演员和剧组放映雷恩·威尔逊的新电影《摇滚岁月中》。
All are welcome. So that was also happening. So what happening? All right. Fast fact number three, this episode is a baby shower. So I'm going to tell you some stuff about baby showers. You did a deep dive on baby showers. I did.
欢迎所有人参加。所以这也是当时正在发生的事。所以正发生着呢。好吧。趣事三号，这一集是一个婴儿淋浴派对。所以我要告诉你们一些关于婴儿淋浴派对的事情。你对婴儿淋浴派对做了一番深入研究。我确实研究了。
What is there to know? It's a baby coming. Get some presents. Get everyone ready. What else is there to know? Well, baby showers are believed to date all the way back to the Egyptian and Greek civilizations. Whoa. But baby showers, as we know them today, began during the baby boom era of World War II.
有什么好了解的？不就是一个婴儿要出生了吗。收点礼物。让大家准备好。还有什么好了解的？好吧，人们认为婴儿淋浴派对可以追溯到古埃及和古希腊文明。哇。但我们今天所熟知的婴儿淋浴派对，始于二战后的婴儿潮时期。
So traditionally, the baby shower was thrown by a close family member or a friend and the mother-to-be opened gifts in a decorated chair. Well, Jan has a very decorated chair. I noticed. Yeah. Thank you, Party Planning Committee. Thank you, Phyllis. Well, I think Angela did it because Phyllis is making her do everything.
所以传统上，婴儿淋浴派对是由亲近的家庭成员或朋友举办的，准妈妈会在一把装饰精美的椅子上拆礼物。好吧，简有一把装饰非常精美的椅子。我注意到了。是的。谢谢你，派对策划委员会。谢谢你，菲利斯。好吧，我觉得是安吉拉干的，因为菲利斯逼她做所有事情。
So thank you, Angela. Okay. I don't know. Well, listen, nowadays we have all kinds of ways that we can celebrate a new baby. And here are some new updated baby showers, a diaper shower. That's where all you bring are diapers in different sizes. It's like if you go to your baby shower, it's like you went to Costco and bought out all the diapers.
所以谢谢你，安吉拉。好吧，我不知道。好吧，听着，现在我们有很多种方式来庆祝一个新宝宝的诞生。这里有一些最新、与时俱进的婴儿淋浴派对，比如尿布派对。那是所有人带的只有不同尺寸的尿布。这就好比你去婴儿淋浴派对，就像去了好市多把所有的尿布都买光了一样。
So let's go home with every diaper because diapers are expensive. What's the next one? Grandparent's shower. This is a shower that you throw for the grandparents and you give them stuff to keep at their house for when the baby comes over. Boom. I love you, grandparents, but come on, grandparents, they love to go get that stuff. Yeah.
所以每一个尿布我们都带回家，因为尿布很贵。下一个是什么？祖父母迎婴派对。这是一个为祖父母举办的派对，送给他们一些东西放在家里，等宝宝过来时用。太棒了。爷爷奶奶我爱你们，但是说实话，爷爷奶奶，他们很喜欢去弄那些东西。对的。
I don't know. Here's another one. Okay. I've heard of these, a sprinkle. What? You don't have a baby shower. You have a sprinkle. It sounds like you're going pee.
我不知道。还有这个。好吧。我听说过这种，洒水派对。什么？你们不办迎婴派对，办洒水派对。听起来像你要去尿尿。
It does. This is a shower that you throw for your second or third or fourth babies to collect maybe some of the things if you are having a baby of a different gender. Right, right. Or if you need to refresh. Oh my God. I just got it. A sprinkle.
确实是。这是为你生第二个、第三个或第四个孩子而办的派对，如果你生的是不同性别的孩子，可以收集一些东西。对的，对的。或者如果你需要更新换代。天哪。我刚刚明白了。洒水派对。
A shower and a sprinkle. Yeah. It's not a full shower. It's just a sprinkle. Every time you say it, I just think of tinkling. I do too. All right, the final one is a sip and see. Does this involve wine?
迎婴派对和洒水派对。对的。这不是完整的派对。只是个洒水派对。你每次说这个词，我都只想到了尿尿。我也是。好吧，最后一个是“来看看吧”。这跟红酒有关吗？
It does. It is a celebration planned by the new parents after the baby has arrived. Oh, you sip and you get to see the baby. Yes. So I have to say what we are going to see in this episode is technically a sip and see. You know what? I have been to a sip and see, but I didn't even know it. I love the name sip and see.
是的。这是宝宝出生后，由新父母策划的庆祝活动。哦，你喝着酒，然后去看宝宝。是的。所以我得说，我们这一集里要看到的，严格来说就是一个“来看看吧”派对。你知道吗？我参加过“来看看吧”派对，但我当时甚至都不知道。我很喜欢“来看看吧”这个名字。
Sip and see. Can I have a sip and see for my new puppy? Can I do that? Yes. Okay, good. That's all I got, Angie. Anything you want to add? Do you have a Kinsey tidbit today?
来看看吧。我能为我的新小狗办一个“来看看吧”派对吗？我可以这样做吗？可以。好吧，太好了。安吉，我只有这些了。你还有什么要补充的吗？你今天有什么金西小八卦吗？
Well, here's a little Kinsey tidbit. One of the things Erin said, which we have talked about before, is how long these scripts came in. You know, they were pretty big episodes, and then we would have to just chisel away, and there was so much that didn't make it to the screen. For example, this episode came in at 49 pages, right? Wait, what? The script for this was 49 pages?
好吧，这里有个金西小八卦。艾伦说过的一件事，也是我们以前讨论过的，就是这些剧本写出来有多长。你知道的，这些都是很大的剧集，然后我们不得不精简，有太多内容都没有进入荧幕。例如，这一集的剧本有49页，对吧？等等，什么？这一集的剧本有49页？
Yeah, 49 pages. That's craziness. And you know how we've talked about how they would sort of rebuild the episodes in editing? Well, Erin had this quote that I absolutely loved. He said that Greg liked to rebuild the ship at sea. Oh, yeah. Isn't that such a great phrase? I love that.
对，49页。太疯狂了。而且你知道我们之前讨论过他们如何在剪辑中重新构建剧集的吗？好吧，艾伦有一句话我非常喜欢。他说格雷格喜欢在海上重建这艘船。哦，对。这不是一个很好的短语吗？我太喜欢了。
I just love that. They would get in the editor's room, man, and they would just carve it up. And I told him, I said, it's always interesting for me now that we have all these scripts. Thank you, James, to see what makes it on the screen and what doesn't and how they move everything around. And I'm always so happy with the final product, you know? But it's a cool thing to see. But I thought that Greg likes to rebuild the ship at sea was like a great phrase.
我只是太喜欢了。他们会进入剪辑室，天哪，然后他们会把它切得粉碎。我告诉他，我说，现在我们有了所有的剧本，对我来说总是很有趣，感谢詹姆斯，看看是什么最终呈现在荧幕上，什么没有，以及他们是如何调整所有东西的。我总是对最终的产品感到很满意，你知道吗？但看到这个很酷。不过我觉得格雷格喜欢在海上重建这艘船是一个很棒的短语。
Well, I think those were really good fast facts, and we've got some more Erin tidbits. We should take a break and get into this episode. I like it. All right, we are back. And you guys, at 12 seconds, everything you need to know about this episode is laid out by Jim. Jim has a dry erase board, and he's going to tell you everything you need to know about this episode.
嗯，我觉得这些是非常好的快讯，我们还有更多的艾伦花絮。我们应该休息一下，然后进入这一集。我喜欢。好吧，我们回来了。大家注意，在12秒的时候，吉姆列出了关于这一集你需要知道的一切。吉姆有一块干擦白板，他要告诉你关于这一集你需要知道的一切。
Sam, can you play that clip? Jan is about to have a baby with a sperm donor, and Michael is preparing for the birth of a watermelon with Dwight. Now, this baby will be related to Michael through delusion. There you go. That pretty much sums it up. That could have been the summary. I know, right?
萨姆，你能放一下那个片段吗？简即将和一个精子捐赠者生一个孩子，迈克尔正和德怀特一起为生一个西瓜做准备。现在，这个孩子将通过妄想与迈克尔有亲缘关系。就这样。这差不多总结了。这本来可以作为总结的。我懂的，对吧？
When I saw that, I was like, well, that's everything you need to know. Did you catch the Dwight? I know, I was about to say, Ann, you got a real good Dwight in there. Well, it's true. Dwight is walking around. He's got a watermelon in his smock that he's wearing, an apron. They fastened like a smock to hold the baby. Yeah, the watermelon baby.
当我看到那个时，我就想，好吧，这就是你需要知道的一切。你注意到德怀特了吗？我知道，我正要说，安，你在里面学了一个很棒的德怀特。好吧，这是真的。德怀特走来走去了。他的罩衫里揣着一个西瓜，他穿着围裙。他们像罩衫一样系着来抱孩子。对，西瓜宝宝。
Do you have some Phil Shea trivia about this? I do. Yay! I talked to Phil Shea for about an hour yesterday. Propmaster extraordinaire. I know. And we are going to have him on for an extended interview because he has got just some great info and stories.
你有什么关于这一集的菲尔·谢伊的冷知识吗？我有。太棒了！我昨天和菲尔·谢伊聊了一个小时左右。无与伦比的道具大师。我知道。我们打算邀请他进行一次深度采访，因为他有太多的好信息和故事了。
I can't wait. We need to have Aaron Schur on, too. We really do. Let's load it up. All right. We had a fan question from Lisa W. How many watermelons were needed to do the practice birth scene with Michael and Dwight? Phil said, in total, we used about 30 watermelons for this whole episode.
我等不及了。我们也需要邀请亚伦·舒尔。我们真的需要。把它加载进来。好的。我们有一个来自丽莎·W的粉丝提问。在迈克尔和德怀特的练习分娩场景中，总共需要多少个西瓜？菲尔说，在整集中我们总共用了大约30个西瓜。
Oh, because he straps it into the stroller later. Yes. These scenes and for later. And Phil said, you know, it's great living in Southern California because you can get watermelons all year. So it wasn't a problem. Okay. Yeah.
哦，因为他后来把它绑在婴儿车里了。是的。这些场景还有后面的。菲尔说，你知道，住在南加州太棒了，因为你一年四季都能买到西瓜。所以这不是问题。好的。对的。
Fan catch from Evelyn V said, at one minute 41 seconds, I think I can see other stains from when the watermelon crashed into the ground on previous takes. I looked at it. Evelyn, I think that's a stain from something else. I don't think it's a watermelon. I feel like as Pam, I have walked up to the front of Michael's desk and I've looked down at my feet enough in scenes. I recognize that stain.
伊芙琳·V的粉丝抓拍说，在1分41秒时，我想我可以看到以前拍摄时西瓜撞到地上的其他污渍。我看过了。伊芙琳，我认为那是其他东西的污渍。我不认为那是西瓜。我觉得作为帕姆，我在场景中走到迈克尔的办公桌前，低头看脚下的次数够多了。我认得那个污渍。
I don't know what that's from. I don't think it was watermelons. I don't know what to make of that other than maybe we should have splurged for new carpet. I think Michael needs new carpet. Yeah. We had this letter from Ben M. in Chicago. I am an ER doctor and whenever I'm teaching medical students how to deliver a baby, I like to show them the cold open from this episode.
我不知道那是从哪里来的。我不认为那是西瓜。除了也许我们应该大方一点买个新地毯之外，我不知道该怎么解释。我觉得迈克尔需要新地毯。是的。我们收到了来自芝加哥本·M的这封信。我是一名急诊室医生，每当我教医学生如何接生时，我都喜欢给他们看这一集的冷开场。
Get out. Yes. This reinforces to them that newborns are very slippery. Oh, come on. It helps teach them that you must always support the baby's head and neck and also hold an arm or a leg immediately after delivery. It is a very funny cold open, but also extremely accurate. Wow.
得了吧。是的。这向他们强化了新生儿非常滑这一事实。哦，拜托。这有助于教导他们，在分娩后，你必须始终托住婴儿的头部和颈部，并立即握住一只手臂或一条腿。这是一个非常有趣的冷开场，但也极其准确。哇。
Yeah. Well, Erin told me that this whole cold open was Greg's idea, the watermelon, the whole thing. Okay. He had this whole idea and Erin just ran with it. It's funny you say that because when I spoke with Phil, he said, I think Greg had an affinity for Gallagher and that's why you see so many watermelon gags on our show. That is very funny.
是的。嗯，艾伦告诉我，整个冷开场都是格雷格的主意，西瓜，整个事情。好的。他有这个完整的想法，艾伦只是照着做了。你这么说很有趣，因为当我跟菲尔谈话时，他说，我想格雷格对加拉格尔有一种喜爱，这就是为什么你在我们的节目中看到这么多西瓜笑料的原因。这非常有趣。
Yeah. The comedian Gallagher, he used to smash watermelons and if you're on the front row, you just get splattered. Yeah. I think that was it. Erin told me because after he spoke with you, he came to the DM. Oh, he found you. He DMed.
是的。喜剧演员加拉格尔，他过去常砸西瓜，如果你坐在第一排，你就会被溅到。是的。我想就是那样。艾伦告诉我，因为在跟你谈过之后，他来了DM。哦，他找到你了。他发私信了。
Oh, good. He said this cold open was the first thing they shot and it was his first time on set for the office and he kept laughing out loud and Greg had to say to him, Erin, this is not everybody loves Raymond. It's not a live show. You can't laugh out loud. He was like, oh no. Yes.
哦，太好了。他说这个冷开场是他们拍的第一场戏，这也是他第一次来到《办公室》的片场，他一直在大笑，格雷格不得不对他说，艾伦，这不是《人人都爱雷蒙德》。这不是现场秀。你不能大笑。他当时就像，哦，不。是的。
He told me that it became a thing he became very self-conscious about because he'd only ever worked in four camera where they encourage you to laugh and laugh and laugh. And then he had to start suppressing the laugh and suppressing the laugh. And he said, after a long day of work and suppressing the laugh, he would go home and just burp constantly because he had given himself some type of indigestion from holding and laughter all day. Oh. Well, you guys, this was very hard to watch without laughing for all of us.
他告诉我，这成了他变得非常自我意识的一件事，因为他以前只在四机位（情景喜剧）工作过，在那里他们鼓励你笑，笑，笑。然后他不得不开始压抑笑声，压抑笑声。他说，经过一天漫长的工作和压抑笑声后，他回家就会不停地打嗝，因为他整天忍住笑给自己搞出了某种消化不良。哦。好吧，伙计们，我们所有人看这一集不笑都非常困难。
And if you go to one minute, 11 seconds, Phyllis had to put her head down because she was laughing so hard. The shot of the bullpen reacting. Yeah, was so funny to me. Well, there is a lot in this episode that we could not get through. Oh man, the conference room, we'll get there. I think we should get to the party planning committee now because they have been very busy decorating the conference room for the shower.
如果你看到1分11秒，菲利斯不得不把头埋起来，因为她笑得太厉害了。大办公室里的人做出反应的镜头。是的，我觉得太有趣了。好吧，这一集里有很多内容我们没能讲完。天哪，会议室，我们会讲到的。我觉得我们现在应该进入派对策划委员会了，因为他们一直在为迎婴派对忙着装饰会议室。
They have two bowls of M&Ms. So I talked to Erin about this and I said, who came up with Astrid and Chevy? And he said Astrid was definitely Greg. He thought it'd be funny to see that name on an M&M. And then Chevy, he couldn't remember who came up with that. He said he thinks the room kind of pitched names. It's funny when I saw the bowls of M&Ms with the names, that was like a really popular thing.
他们有两碗M&M巧克力豆。所以我跟艾伦谈了这件事，我说，谁想出了阿斯特里德和雪佛莱？他说阿斯特里德绝对是格雷格想的。他认为在M&M巧克力豆上看到这个名字会很有趣。然后是雪佛莱，他记不清是谁想出来的了。他说他觉得房间里的人有点像是在集思广益。有趣的是，当我看到写着名字的M&M巧克力豆碗时，那就像是一件非常受欢迎的事情。
It might still be popular where you can get these personalized M&Ms. Oh, I went to the website. It's still a whole thing. High school graduation, anniversaries, and I did this for my parents. My parents' anniversary. I got M&Ms with their names on it. Well, when we did the Jim and Pam wedding episode, Greg threw the cast of viewing party that was kind of like a little mini reception.
现在可能还是很受欢迎，你可以在那里买到这些个性化的M&M巧克力豆。哦，我去了他们的网站。这仍然是一整套东西。高中毕业、周年纪念，我为我父母做过这个。我父母的结婚纪念日。我买了我父母名字的M&M巧克力豆。嗯，当我们拍摄吉姆和帕姆的婚礼那一集时，格雷格举办了剧组观看派对，有点像一个小型的招待会。
And he had bowls of M&Ms that said Jim and Pam. He clearly was a big fan. He loved that you could personalize an M&M. I know. Well, they've gotten the name wrong though. The party planning committee has asked Turd. Phyllis is like, that can't be right. Angela is like, Michael wrote down Astrid.
Michael said, yeah, it's like the name of a Viking princess. So of course, I had to research Astrid. I didn't research Astrid. And he is right. Michael is right. According to the internet, Astrid has Norse, Danish, and Swedish roots. It can mean godly strength or divine beauty. And the name Astrid has been used by Norway's royal family for hundreds of years.
You know, Michael is annoyed by their effort. He says, Phyllis, we gave you a whole golden shower. I want my golden shower. He does. And then he has this talking head where he says he's going to love this baby even if it isn't his, like that dog that nursed the tiger cub, right, bizarre, but also beautiful. It happens. Jenna, I looked it up.
And there are so many stories of dogs nursing tigers. But the one that caught my eye was on the Today Show in August of 2008. That's when we shot this episode. I know. And there was a safari park in Kansas with a white tiger named Sassy who had cubs, but she was too sassy to nurse them. Okay. So a golden retriever stepped in, Isabella.
Well, I would expect that from a golden retriever. I really would. What a good dog. Anyway, it just cracked me up that on the Today Show, there was a whole thing about Sassy and Isabella. And I think it ended up in our episode. Clearly it did. Michael is going to bark orders at Phyllis.
She's doing a talking head. I was supposed to be glaring at her in the background. And if you go to four minutes, 11 seconds, you can see me talking to Andy. And I'm so delighted that Phyllis is messing up. And then Michael walks in and kind of yells at her and says, make the party, make the party. And then he leaves and Phyllis starts pumping the balloon. Well, Steve improvised walking back in and saying, pop it, pop it. He did.
He did. That was all improv. We just started cracking up. I thought I could see you starting to break in the background of that. And Phyllis is starting to break too. So now Jim is at his desk and Pam is trying to tell him this story. I loved this. It was so funny.
When she's like, Sarah Kaya comes in and he goes, oh wait, Sarah Kaya comes in and she's like, no, Sarah Kaya comes in. And then at the very end of the scene when Dwight's like, who's Sarah Kaya comes in? That was improvised. It was. Rain improvised that. That's not in the script. Oh my gosh.
I watched this and I feel like I have had these conversations. Yes. 100%. And I love the line when she's like, why can't you just be in art school with me? Because she's trying so hard to tell him the story and you know, this is the beginning of this storyline with Jim and Pam where we're going to show that this distance has gone on for a while and maybe they're not connecting as easily as they used to. You know, long distance relationships are hard and particularly when the people involved
in your new life, the other person doesn't know. And it's kind of hard to keep track. Oh, yes. I mean, we experience this all the time when we go on locations or I remember Lee went on location to shoot a movie and he was directing a film. And he's trying to tell me this hilarious story about some prop mishap that happened and everyone was laughing about these prop glasses. And I'm just like, I don't know who any of these people are.
And what's really hard about it is that I like to be able to imagine the people or where they are. And we've talked about this when we get to a new place where like, send me a video of where you are so that when I'm talking to you, I know what your little apartment looks like or I know what your room looks like. Yeah. I have to have that. Otherwise I'm a little unsettled because I can't picture where you are.
Yes. So I feel like that's what Pam and Jim are up against right now. Yeah. He doesn't know her world and it's some of that location situation kind of stuff. I love the next scene. I love it so much. Angela is preparing this poster board full of baby photos because they're going to play a game where you have to guess which baby photo belongs to which employee and Andy
comes in and he mistakes Phyllis's baby photo for Angela. Will you please tell me about shooting this scene, Angela? Well, one of the reasons I storm off is because I started to laugh. I could tell. That was me trying to get out of there before you saw me laughing on camera. So here's the thing, Greg directed this episode, right? And he said, you guys, can you bring in your actual baby photos? And he said, if you don't have a baby photo, it could be like when you're a toddler.
Just can I get photos of you guys when you're little? And we did, right? Yes. We got a lot of fan mail about that. Were these actual photos of the cast? They were. Yeah. There's three people who aren't on the poster, me, John, and Steve.
Everyone else is an actual baby photo from their childhood. Including Amy Ryan. She's up there. Yes. And so was Mindy. I mean, we're all on the board. Yes. We're all on the board.
We're bringing in today. Do you want to share with them? You brought in your baby photo, the one that was on the board with your little hand up on your little chubby cheek. I know. I know. You guys, it's really me. I get asked this all the time.
And my mom, I called my mom and I said, mom, we're doing the baby shower episode and it's my baby photo and I want to know everything about it. She said, oh, I have several more of that same day where we put you in different poses. Oh, so there's more. But here's what my mom said. She took me to JCPenney's at the Acadiana Shopping Mall in Lafayette, Louisiana. I was around six months old and apparently I was born with just a ton of hair and it was sort of an auburn brown.
She said I had so much hair. Just right out of the gate, I had tons of hair and so she tried to style it for the photo. I was like, mom, you gave me like a mohawk with bangs. So yeah, she said she had tried to put a little ribbon at the top. That would have made more sense. Right. But I don't know what fell out or something.
And then they propped me up on my hand like that. It's so funny because I remember those photo studio photo shoots. That was a thing of my childhood as well. And they would have these carpeted blocks and you would like be propped up on a little carpeted block. I'm propped up because I can't sit yet. Really? Yes.
Anyway, there you go. That's my actual baby photo, you guys. Well, since mine wasn't on the board, I tell you what, I'll post mine on the office ladies pod so you can see me as a baby too. Yes. And I'll ask my mom if she can find any other photos from that particular photo shoot. Please. As Michael is preparing for Jan's arrival, he needs to tell Holly that he's going to
be kind of cold to her today because he needs to protect Jan's feelings. Jan's bloated feelings. Yeah. Jan is going to come in, she's going to be so unattractive. And Holly is very attractive. And yeah, he just wants to be sensitive. So he warns her. But then Jan arrives.
She's not pregnant. She has a baby. And she looks amazing. Yeah. But she's had the baby. We had a fan question from Brittany Y, Sarah M, and many more. Who is the baby that played Astrid? I will tell you, thanks to James Apedia.
First of all, you know, babies are played by many babies. Sometimes there are set of twins. Like in the case of Cece, Cece was the set of twins and it was the same twin girls all through the show. They were absolute sweethearts and I loved them. But sometimes, especially with a baby this little, it's like three babies, five babies, lots of babies. And they're all up with several different babies and then a different toddler.
Yes. So this is because there are rules about babies working on a set. They can only work for like 20 minutes. And I think that's a good thing. Yes. Also, if you have a baby and one of them's fussy, you can swap them out for a different baby. They're all dressed the same.
You go backstage and there's like six babies in the same outfit. So Astrid was played first by a set of twins and another baby. Here's the crazy thing. The twins' names were Matthew and Joey Levinson. Crazy. Right. And they were playing Jan Levinson's baby. Yes.
The other baby was Harvey Green. So her babies were the Levinson Green babies. Okay. All right. And then that was on one day. The other day, we had a set of triplets playing Astrid. They were Chase, Chloe and Juliette Purcell. So those are all the babies.
We also had a fake baby. We did have a fake baby, yeah. And it's really funny because if you look at the call sheet scene by scene, it'll say real baby or fake baby. Like what we're using in the scene and they would stagger them, right? Because the babies could only work for 20 minutes. So you'd have a scene with a real baby and then a scene with a fake baby. Well, Michael walks out of the kitchen and he sees Jan with the baby.
I can't imagine how he felt. He'd been to all of his birthing classes with her and then he was sort of left out of this big moment and he confronts Jan about it. This is one of my favorite couplets of dialogue from the whole episode. Okay. It's so rich. Michael says, why didn't you call me? I could have helped.
Jan said, well, the birth instructor thought it wasn't a good idea for you to be there. So Michael says, oh man, him, that guy. He had no sense of humor and I proved him wrong in so many ways and it just made me think about these classes. I wish we could have seen Michael trying to do comedy bits with like a birthing instructor. I would have loved to seen that scene. I think what Jan has done to Michael is so cruel. I know that she didn't call him and also in that scene, Jan is like, Michael, you don't
know what I have been through and he said, no, no, I don't. And I love Steve's delivery on that. I know. I guess she feels bad and she lets him hold the baby, but it says the baby has to stay in the car seat. And then Michael has this very sweet talking head where he says he loves babies and he tries to pick them up and hold one every day. It just nourishes him.
And then we see this really sweet montage of Michael and babies and the babies love him. They really do. Well, that's because it's Steve Carell is holding the baby. I know. I know. I wouldn't have loved Michael, but Steve is a natural with kids. I know. We had a fan question from Evan L and Stacy M in the scenes where Michael is holding all
the babies. Were those hired actors or did the crew just go out and let people line up to have their baby held by Steve Carell? All of those babies were the children of our writers and our crew. So here is a list of the babies. At nine minutes, you have baby on the street. This is Emma Holland, daughter of our editor, Dean Holland. And that is also Dean's wife, Tasha.
At nine minutes, nine seconds, I'm calling this one baby at the bathroom. That baby is Theodore Grandi. The woman is Sage Grandi. And this is the son of our writer, Charlie Grandi. At nine minutes, 15 seconds, we have double baby. And that is our writer, Mike Sher's wife, JJ Philbin, and their baby, William, along with our camera operator, Matt Sohn's wife, Melissa, and their baby, Devon. And the final baby at nine minutes, 17 seconds, that is Avery Ferrell, the daughter of our
writer, Anthony Ferrell. The woman was a background performer, but that's Anthony loading the stroller into the car. So we had had kind of like a little mini baby boom on our set. All of these kids were around the same age. I texted with Dean, he said his daughter, Emma, is now 13 years old. And she tells everybody that she's one of the babies on the office. And Angela, I know you get asked a lot about Isabel because she was right around the same
age too. Yes. Isabel just had her 13th birthday. There was this baby boom and it was really fun for us to have our babies on set. And I get asked if she was in this episode and she wasn't. And you know why? The day they filmed the scene with all the babies was my day off. And I wanted to be home with my baby, not bringing my baby to work.
So I wasn't in it and they said, don't worry, Angela, we're going to get Isabel in there. And they did. She ended up having a very fun day on set years later at CC's dance recital. I can't wait. I know. Well, Michael's going to try to make the best of it. Okay. He is going to present Astrid to the office and they're going to go into the conference
room. And he does the lion king and holds the car seat over his head. I know. I hope that was fake baby day. That was fake baby. And that was all scripted. Oh boy. Well, when we move into the conference room, Kevin is like, you know, the fact that the
babies here kind of ruins the games and Michael is like, no, it doesn't, no, it doesn't. It kind of did. Well, you know, the theme is a baby shower and all the games are for an expecting mother. No, it was really awkward, but there are a lot of scenes in this conference room baby shower that didn't make it. I'm going to share a few. The first one is Jenna, one of the funniest things I have had to witness and we could not get through it.
Kevin thinks he might be the sperm donor and the look on Jan's face is amazing. Sam, can you play that from the deleted scenes? Hey, Jan, you went to a sperm bank? Yes, I did. I donated sperm. Oh, maybe I'm the father. Well, this is a highly exclusive establishment. Next to the IHOP?
Well, I paid for an ideal specimen. Are you saying Kevin is not an ideal specimen? This is a wonderful shower, everyone. Thank you. I might have done it with Jan. It's not Kevin's. We could not get through it whenever Brian said, you mean the one by IHOP, just every single time because Melora's reaction as Jan was so good and then she says she paid for
premium sperm, which we learned might have been anti-Rodix. I love there are so many deleted scenes about who the father of Jan's baby is. We've got Andy Roddick, maybe Kevin. There's a lot of speculation that it's Hunter, and none of these scenes actually made it into the episodes, so what do you think about that? Do you think if something didn't make it in, it counts? Or does it not count if it doesn't make it in the episode? So yeah, what is the canon, right?
Yes, exactly. What is the canon of the show? Well, I guess it would have to be what aired, right? So then that would mean it's just a mystery. It's a mystery. She paid top dollar for it, though. That's what we know. Yeah, that's all we know and all will ever truly know.
And I think the one thing we also know is that it's not Michaels because he had to wear two condoms. We know that. Yeah. We know whose baby it's not. That's right. I got this cool letter from Kristen B. She has a background catch and she said, the first time I watched this episode after having my son, I almost jumped out of my seat when
I saw the pink donut pillow on Jan's chair at the baby shower. I had never noticed it prior to giving birth, but after I got one at the hospital myself, I just have to say this is amazing and 10-10 for attention to detail. That is a great background catch. I noticed it as well. I loved that detail. I did too. I don't know if you guys also noticed behind Jan's chair, there's a little table and on
the table is a big bird stuffed animal. There is a deleted scene where Michael tells Phyllis he wants storks. She said she couldn't get storks and he's like, look, I barely got Jan to even come today. This needs to be a big party. If you can't get a stork, I at least want Big Bird. And the best Phyllis could do is she got a Big Bird stuffed animal. Wow.
Yeah. Oh, that is so great. Well the group gives Jan her gift. It's a stroller. I think this is a very nice gift. It's a very nice gift because it's a big ticket item, but she's already got a stroller. She has an orbit. That Oscar tells us costs $1,200.
Yeah. Dwight is curious. He's like, I need to see how good the stroller really is. Yeah. He said his whole bomb shelter bunker thing that he built didn't even cost that much. And he needs to see what the stroller's made of if it's going to cost that much. So yeah, he wheels the stroller out and then Jan is going to sing to the baby. Oh, Jenna.
How did you get through this? How did you get through it? It was like bite the inside of your cheek, don't make eye contact with anyone, and also at the same time in total awe of Malora. Yes. Who has an amazing singing voice and performs as a singer, guys. Yes. She has albums.
Yes. She's a singer. She just owned this moment so wholeheartedly. There is a scene, Jenna, that was in the script that we shot. I remember shooting it because the timing and everything in it was amazing. So Jan is singing, Son of a Preacher Man. She's belting it out and Ryan comes in urgently to tell her something. She won't stop singing and I printed out the script here, Jenna.
Just read right here. Okay. So I'm going to be Ryan. Yeah. Okay. And you guys forgive my singing. Okay. Was a Son of a Preacher Man, yes he was.
Hey Jan. He was. Jan. Yes he was. You parked in the handicap spot. Keys are in my purse. I'll just, I'll take them. Did I do a good?
嘿，简。他是。简。是的，他是。你停在残疾人车位上了。钥匙在我的钱包里。我这就，我来拿。我表现得好吗？
You did great. Sorry to make you guys suffer through my singing. Malora was amazing. She never missed a beat. She sang where her keys were. It was amazing. I did a mini deep dive on Son of a Preacher Man. Did you really?
你做得棒极了。抱歉让你们听我唱歌受折磨。玛洛拉太棒了。她节奏从未出错。她唱出了她钥匙所在的地方。这太棒了。我对《牧师之子的儿子》进行了一次小小的深入研究。真的吗？
Yes. I think we should take a break and when we come back I'll tell you what I found. Okay. All right. We are back and I'm going to start us off with a fan question from Yvette M and Alexandra S. Why was the song Son of a Preacher Man chosen for Jan to sing to her baby? I asked Erin who picked the song and Erin said he isn't sure if Mindy picked it per say but she was pushing it.
是的。我想我们应该休息一下，等我们回来后，我告诉你们我发现了什么。好的。好的。我们回来了，首先我要分享一个来自伊维特·M和亚历山大·S的粉丝问题。为什么会选择《牧师之子的儿子》这首歌让简唱给她的宝宝听？我问过埃林是谁选的这首歌，埃林说他不确定是不是明迪主动挑的，但确实是她在力推。
He said I don't remember how exactly it came up in the writer's room but the minute it was out there Mindy was like that's got to be it. That has got to be it. So I think we have Mindy to thank for that. I got curious about the song so I did a little deep dive on it. Son of a Preacher Man was written by John Hurley and Ronnie Wilkins. It was recorded by Dusty Springfield in 1968 and her version is most popular. It's been covered many times by many artists.
他说我不记得这首歌是怎么具体在编剧室里提出来的了，但这首歌一出现，明迪就说“就是它了”。“一定得是它”。所以我想我们得感谢明迪。我对这首歌很好奇，所以我对它做了一点深入研究。《牧师之子的儿子》由约翰·赫利和罗尼·威尔金斯创作。它由达斯蒂·斯普林菲尔德于1968年录制，她的版本最受欢迎。它被许多艺术家翻唱过很多次。
Here's what I found interesting. Apparently the rights to record the song were originally offered to Aretha Franklin. She was the daughter of a preacher and the rumor is that she turned it down because she worried that maybe it might be a little disrespectful but she changed her mind. No. She recorded a cover version of the song just one year later in 1969 for her album Soul Sister. I had to hear it.
这是我发现有趣的地方。显然，这首歌的录制版权最初是提供给艾瑞莎·弗兰克林的。她是牧师的女儿，有传言称她拒绝了，因为她担心这可能有点不尊重，但她后来改变了主意。没有。她仅仅一年后，即1969年，就为她的专辑《灵魂姐妹》录制了这首歌的翻唱版。我不得不听听看。
Sam, will you play it? It's so good, isn't it? She always gives me chills. Dolly Parton also did a cover in 1996 for her album Treasures and it is also a gem. Do you want to hear that one? Yes. Billy Ray was a preacher's son and when his daddy would be, did he come along? When they gathered and started talking, that's when Billy would take me walking.
萨姆，你能放一下吗？这太棒了，不是吗？她总是让我起鸡皮疙瘩。多莉·帕顿也在1996年为她的专辑《珍宝》翻唱过，这也是一颗明珠。你想听那个版本吗？好的。比利·雷是牧师的儿子，当他爸爸来的时候，他会一起来吗？当他们聚在一起开始聊天时，那就是比利带我去散步的时候。
I can listen to these women sing anything. They're legends. They're legends in our podcast today. Do we need to hear Dusties? I think we need to hear Dusties. I mean, we have to hear Dusties. It's Son of a Preacher Man Day today. I mean, I just want to hear all of them.
我能听这些女性唱任何歌。她们是传奇。她们是我们今天播客里的传奇。我们需要听达斯蒂的版本吗？我想我们需要听达斯蒂的。我的意思是，我们必须听达斯蒂的。今天是《牧师之子的儿子》日。我的意思是，我只是想听所有的版本。
I feel so embarrassed that I even attempted to sing it at all to recreate the scene with Ryan. I am so sorry. Billy Ray was a preacher's son and when his daddy would visit, he'd come along. When they gathered and started talking, that's when Billy would take me walking. I threw the bag down, we go walking. Then he looked into my eyes. Lord knows to my surprise, the only one who could ever reach me was the Son of a Preacher
我感到非常尴尬，我居然还试着唱了一下，好在重现与瑞安的那个场景。真的非常抱歉。比利·雷是牧师之子，当他老爸来拜访时，他会一同前来。当他们聚在一起开始交谈，那就是比利带我去散步的时候。我扔下包，我们去散步。然后他凝视着我的双眼。老天爷啊，出乎我的意料，唯一真正能触动我心灵的只有牧师的儿子
Man. All right. So good. All right. All right. Here's what I have to say. Kudos to John Hurley and Ronnie Wilkins, because when you write a song that can be sung by all of these different people with their different spins on it and their different
……男人。好吧。太棒了。好吧。好吧。我要说的是：向约翰·赫利和罗尼·威尔金斯致敬，因为当你写出一首能由所有这些不同的人用他们不同的风格来演唱的歌时，并且用他们不同的
arrangements. And it still knocks your socks off every time. You have written a good song. Yep. One last thing I want to say about Son of a Preacher Man is that when Malora sang it, she improvised the snapping. And you know what? It about got me on the floor.
编曲。每一次依然能震撼到你。你写了一首好歌。是的。关于《牧师之子的儿子》，我想说的最后一件事是，当玛洛拉唱这首歌时，她即兴加入了响指。你知道吗？这差点把我惊艳得跌倒在地。
We were so trying to suppress laughter that one more thing was like the tipping point, you know? So as she's swaying and singing when she just starts doing that snap, I was like, oh Lord, I'm not going to make it. I am not going to make it. There are really great scripted talking heads of people reacting to it. And Stanley had a great one where he was like, I used to like that song. Well, Jim is going to try to describe it to Pam.
我们当时竭力忍住笑，再多一点什么就会成为压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草，你知道吗？所以当她摇摆着唱歌，突然开始打响指时，我想，哦天哪，我撑不下去了。我撑不下去了。那里确实有非常精彩的剧本访谈片段，人们对此作出反应。斯坦利有一个很棒的片段，他说：我以前挺喜欢那首歌的。好吧，吉姆打算试着向帕姆描述它。
She's at the laundromat and she can't hear anything he's saying. Why couldn't she just walk away from the machines, Jenna? You know what? Megan P would like to know the answer to that question as well. Megan, it's the first thing I thought. She hasn't talked to him all day. She finally has free time. Walk away from the machine.
她在洗衣店，根本听不清他在说什么。她为什么不直接从机器旁走开，珍娜？你知道吗？梅根·P也想知道这个问题的答案。梅根，这是我第一个想到的。她一整天都没跟他说话。她好不容易有了空闲时间。离开那台机器吧。
I'll tell you two things. Number one, right before this phone call, there was a bit of the scene that got clipped. Pam is with her friend at the laundromat and they are together and they're talking about a class assignment and she says, oh, just one second, I'm going to take this call. So maybe she felt like she couldn't walk away, but also in the script, there is a version where she does walk away from the machines and the problem is not that the machines are loud. The problem is simply that Pam is not understanding what's so bad about Jan singing to her baby.
我告诉你两件事。第一，就在这通电话之前，有一小段场景被剪掉了。帕姆和她的朋友在自助洗衣店，她们在一起，正在谈论一个课堂作业，然后她说，哦，等一下，我要接个电话。所以也许她觉得她不能走开，但剧本中也有一个版本，她确实从机器旁走开了，问题不在于机器很吵。问题仅仅在于帕姆不明白简对她的宝宝唱歌有什么大不了的。
So it's another kind of like... Miscommunication. Like you had to be there kind of things. But they kept the loud laundry machine version in. I'll have you know, location, alert. The laundromat was Launderland on Sherman Way in North Hollywood, California. I like to throw these out there because there are these office tours where people go around and look at our locations and so I thought, I don't know if you want to see where Pam
所以这又是那种……沟通不畅。就像那种“你当时得在场”的事情。但他们保留了洗衣机声音很大的那个版本。顺便告诉你们，外景地警报。洗衣店是加利福尼亚州北好莱坞谢尔曼路的朗德兰洗衣店。我喜欢把这些说出来，因为有办公室巡回参观，人们会四处参观并寻找我们的外景地，所以我想，我不知道你是否想看帕姆
did her laundry. That's where. Okay. So Pam has this talking head at the laundromat where she says that she's not frustrated. You know, they have these kind of days where they don't connect even when they're together in Scranton and then she discovers that she washed her lipstick and it got all over her green towel. You know, I recently washed Lee's wallet and car key.
洗衣服的地方。就是那儿。好吧。所以帕姆在洗衣店里有这样一段独白，她说她并没有感到沮丧。你知道，他们会有那种即使在斯克兰顿在一起也没有心灵相通的日子，然后她发现自己把口红洗了，弄得她绿色的毛巾上到处都是。你知道，我最近把李的钱包和车钥匙给洗了。
I remember this. You called me and you're like, I washed the keys to the car, his whole entire wallet. Whole wallet. Whole wallet. And now he couldn't find his wallet for days. He was like, where is my wallet? I can't find my wallet. Isn't the laundry basket?
我记得这个。你打电话给我说，我洗了车钥匙，还有他整整一个钱包。整个钱包。整个钱包。然后他好几天找不到钱包。他在想，我的钱包在哪儿？我找不到我的钱包。这不是在洗衣篮里吗？
It was in his pocket. Yeah. It was in the laundry basket and I didn't check the pockets. I threw in the laundry. I found it in the dryer. It went through a full wash cycle, a full dryer cycle. I said, babe, I found your wallet. Wait, did the credit cards all get melty?
它在他口袋里。是的。它在洗衣篮里，我没有检查口袋。我把它扔进了洗衣机。我在烘干机里找到了它。它经历了一个完整的洗衣周期，一个完整的烘干周期。我说，宝贝，我找到你的钱包了。等等，信用卡都融化了吗？
Did he have to get everything new? Lady, his vaccination card was in his wallet. Oh no. All of his credit cards, he was like, oh my God, the vaccination card made it. I was a little afraid at the top. He went out, he bought some gas and the credit cards worked. Well, how about that? So I don't know.
他得把所有东西都换新的吗？天哪，他的疫苗接种卡就在钱包里。哦不。他所有的信用卡，他当时想，哦天哪，疫苗接种卡竟然完好无损。我刚开始有点担心。他出去加了点油，信用卡还能用。嗯，这怎么样？所以我不知道。
I guess you didn't have it. You didn't have it on high heat. No, I did dry on low. And the car key still works because it's one of those little like, yeah, it still works. While all of the singing is going on, Dwight decides he's going to put the stroller to the ultimate test. Yes. I had a fan question from Beth E, Rachel R, Amy F, and Julie G. How many of those strollers
我想你没用。你没有开高温。不，我是用低温烘干的。而且车钥匙还能用，因为它是一个那种小小的……对，它依然能用。正当歌声进行时，德怀特决定对婴儿车进行终极测试。是的。我有一个来自贝丝·E、蕾切尔·R、艾米·F和朱莉·G的粉丝问题。你们用了多少辆那些婴儿车
did you use for the scenes where Dwight tests its durability? This is why I was on the phone with Phil Shea for an hour yesterday. Well, how many did they use? I'll tell you, it started with Phil Shea doing a ton of research to find the perfect stroller for this episode. He said he and Greg had a long talk about how Jan was the kind of person who would have to have the fanciest stroller. In the script, it's written that the stroller is indestructible and he wanted to find something
用来拍摄德怀特测试其耐用性的场景？这就是为什么我昨天和菲尔·谢伊通了一个小时电话。好吧，他们用了多少辆？我来告诉你，一切都始于菲尔·谢伊做了大量的研究，为这一集找到了完美的婴儿车。他说他和格雷格进行了长时间的交谈，讨论简是那种必须拥有最豪华婴儿车的人。剧本里写着这婴儿车是不可摧毁的，他想找一种
that would even look out of place in Scranton. So he went on a search for an indestructible luxury stroller and he found out about the orbit baby stroller, which was kind of a startup stroller at the time. It launched in September of 2006, so just two years before this episode. It was invented by two dads, Brian White and Joseph High. I think it's high, Joseph, I'm sorry if I got that wrong. And they made it because Brian had just become a dad and he said that his back really hurt whenever he was trying to get the baby in and out of the car seat in the car.
甚至在斯克兰顿看起来格格不入的东西。因此，他开始搜寻坚不可摧的豪华婴儿车，他发现了轨道婴儿车（Orbit Baby），这在当时算是一款初创公司的婴儿车。它于2006年9月推出，也就是这一集播出前两年。它由两位父亲布莱恩·怀特和约瑟夫·海共同发明。我想是海，约瑟夫，如果我记错了请原谅。他们制作它是因为布莱恩刚成为父亲，他说每次试图把婴儿放进或抱出车里的安全座椅时，他的背都痛得厉害。
So in his garage, they made a wooden prototype. They studied all kinds of things, but they also sought to use green materials. I like these fellas. Yeah, and this car seat was cool because Phil said it looked kind of weird, but it also rotates 360 degrees. So Phil was like, it was so cool. Like if you want to get your baby out of the car and not remove the car seat, you can swivel it and then you can get your baby out of the car really easy.
所以在他的车库里，他们制作了一个木制原型。他们研究了各种各样的东西，但他们也力求使用环保材料。我喜欢这两个小伙子。是的，这个安全座椅很酷，因为菲尔说它看起来有点奇怪，但它也可以360度旋转。所以菲尔觉得，这太酷了。如果你想把宝宝抱出车外又不想拆卸安全座椅，你可以转动它，然后你就能非常轻松地把宝宝抱出车外了。
Well, Jenna, you know, Phil Shea had a few extra orbits left over and I was a new mom on set and he always was looking out for us and he said, Ange, do you want one of these orbit strollers? They're pretty amazing. And I said, yeah. And that was my favorite thing about it too, what you just said. You could pivot and it would lock into place. So if you swiveled it, it could face left, right, front, back, and it would lock into
好吧，珍娜，你知道的，菲尔·谢伊多出了几个轨道婴儿车，我是片场的新妈妈，他总是很关照我们，他说，安吉，你想要其中一辆轨道婴儿车吗？它们挺神奇的。我说，好的。这也是我最喜欢它的地方，就是你刚刚说的那个。你可以旋转它，它会锁定到位。所以如果你旋转它，它可以朝左、右、前、后，并且它会锁定在
place. Not only was it great when you got your baby out of the car seat, what I loved is you could attach it to the stroller and let's say you're on a walk and the sun is kind of beating down and you don't want to put the little flap over your baby because your baby wants to be able to see where you're going, you could just pivot so then the baby could look at everything on the right side of the street or everything on the left side or look at you. It was so great.
位置上。不仅当你把宝宝从安全座椅里抱出来时它很好用，我最喜欢的是你可以把它安装在婴儿车上，比方说你在散步，太阳有点晒，你不想把小遮阳篷拉下来，因为你的宝宝希望能够看到你们要去哪里，你只需旋转一下，宝宝就能看到街道右侧的一切，或者左侧的一切，或者看着你。这太棒了。
I love that Phil gave you a stroller and that he gave you a chair from work bus. I know. Do you have any more things? I'm sure I do. Maybe your memory will be jogged as we go along. As we go through the episodes. Well, Phil said that he called Brian on the phone and he was like, listen, I've researched your stroller and I want to put it on the television show, The Office.
我很高兴菲尔送了你一辆婴儿车，还送了你一把工作公车上的椅子。我懂。你还有别的东西吗？我确信我有的。随着我们继续看下去，也许你的记忆会被唤醒。当我们重温这些剧集时。好吧，菲尔说他给布莱恩打了电话，他说，听着，我研究了你的婴儿车，我想把它放在电视剧《办公室》里。
And he told him the storyline and Brian agreed to send us 10 strollers. And then Brian flew out and watched the taping. Phil also said the stroller really was indestructible. He's not kidding. There are so many deleted scenes of Rain as Dwight doing things to that stroller and the stroller just keeps on trekking. There's way more. Phil told me that one of his favorite things to do was to reach out to these smaller companies
他把剧情告诉了布莱恩，布莱恩同意给我们寄10辆婴儿车。然后布莱恩飞过来观看了拍摄。菲尔还说，这辆婴儿车真的是坚不可摧的。他可没开玩笑。有很多雷恩饰演的德怀特对那辆婴儿车做各种事情的删减片段，而那辆婴儿车依然一直在正常经受摧毁。还有更多。菲尔告诉我，他最喜欢的事情之一就是联系这些较小的公司
that didn't normally do national advertising and feature their products on the show or collaborate with them. And he said, another one of the reasons that you saw all of the local foods or the local sodas on The Office was because one of our characters is eating like Lay's potato chips. That could be a conflict with maybe another big national potato chip brand that would have a national commercial running during our show. So we weren't allowed. So his choice was he could tape over Lay's or create a fakey bag, chip bag, right?
他们通常不做全国广告，并在节目中展示他们的产品或与他们合作。他说，你看到《办公室》里出现所有当地食品或当地苏打水的另一个原因是因为我们的其中一个角色在吃乐事薯片。这可能会与另一个可能在我们的节目中播放全国广告的大型全国薯片品牌产生冲突。所以我们是不被允许的。所以他的选择是，他可以在乐事上贴胶带，或者制作一个假冒的薯片袋，对吧？
He said, but what he liked to do was feature products, local products like a hers chip, a smaller company that is not going to be in competition for these national spots. And that's another way that he focused in on the orbit. He would try to find these companies that could be approved. Well, I love that because, you know, we love supporting small business. Yeah. Well, the orbit stroller is still available and it is now a big business. I saw online you can get one at Nordstrom.
她说，但她最喜欢做的是主打产品，比如赫尔的薯片这样的小众本地产品，这种小公司不会去和这些全国性品牌竞争。这也是她关注重点的另一种方式。她会试着去寻找那些可以通过审核的公司。我很喜欢这样，因为，你知道的，我们很喜欢支持小企业。是的。嗯，Orbit婴儿车现在依然买得到，而且现在已经是一家大企业了。我看到网上说你在诺德斯特龙就能买到。
Well Jan has done singing. She's pooped out. I mean, all that singing is going to tire you out. Yeah. She wants to take a nap. She gives the baby to Michael and she says, when I wake up, I want to talk to you about Astrid's 529, which I looked up. It's like a savings plan for college.
简唱完歌了。她累垮了。我是说，唱那么多歌会让你筋疲力尽的。对。她想去小睡一会儿。她把孩子交给迈克尔，然后她说，等我醒来，我想跟你谈谈阿斯特丽德的529计划，我查过了，这就像是一个大学储蓄计划。
Yeah. So what? Michael has to go to all the birthing classes, but he doesn't get to be there for the birth of the baby. And now he's going to contribute to the college fund. That's what it sounds like. Jan needs to go buh-buh. I agree.
是啊。所以呢？迈克尔得去上所有的分娩课，但他却不能在孩子出生时在场。现在他还要为大学基金出资。听起来就是这样。简得去嘘嘘了。我同意。
Well, Michael only holds the baby for a short time. He's not feeling that connection and he gives the baby to Phyllis. Yeah. First, Michael has to go to the warehouse. He needs some advice from Daryl. We had a fan question from Ethan B. Did Steve improvise the moment when he asks if he can hold Daryl? They get on this runner where Daryl's like, do you want to hold this?
好吧，迈克尔只抱了一会儿孩子。他没有那种连接感，于是他把孩子交给了菲利斯。是的。首先，迈克尔得去仓库。他需要向达里尔征求一些建议。我们收到了来自伊森·B的粉丝提问：当史蒂夫问他是否可以抱抱达里尔时，那个时刻是他即兴发挥的吗？他们进行了一段这样的对话，达里尔说，你想抱这个吗？
Do you want to hold that? And see if you have a connection, do you want to hold me? No, you guys, that was in the script. That whole scene was scripted just like that. Well, Jan is still sleeping in the deleted scenes. She's like snoring and everyone's looking at her. She's covered herself with the plastic tablecloth from the shower and she wakes up and has a pretty amazing exchange with Holly.
你想抱那个吗？看看你有没有那种连接感，你想抱抱我吗？不，伙计们，那是剧本里的。整场戏就像那样都是写在剧本里的。在被删减的片段里，简还在睡觉。她好像在打呼噜，每个人都在看着她。她用茶话会上的塑料桌布把自己盖了起来，然后她醒了过来，和霍莉有了一段非常精彩的对话。
Where she realizes what we have realized, which is that Holly has a little bit of Michael Scott in her. Yeah. There's been some real Michael Scott jokes here. Yeah. And Jan is like, oh, I get it. Funny. Mm-hmm.
在这段对话里，她意识到了我们已经意识到的事情，那就是霍莉身上有一点迈克尔·斯科特的影子。是的。这里有一些真正的迈克尔·斯科特的笑话。是的。然后简就说，噢，我明白了。有趣。嗯哼。
But Astrid is now with Angela and Andy. I love the scene so much. Angela, please tell me everything about putting all these vegetables on this baby. All right. They had the table completely laid out. They had it all staged. They had the mom with the baby in the wings standing right there. And literally right before action, the mom put the baby down.
但阿斯特丽德现在和安吉拉以及安迪在一起。我太喜欢这一幕了。安吉拉，请把把所有这些蔬菜放在这个宝宝身上的事统统告诉我。好的。他们把桌子完全布置好了。他们把一切都摆好了。妈妈和宝宝就在侧幕条那里随时准备着。就在喊开始前的最后一秒，妈妈把宝宝放下了。
And then I just put that big giant fake piece of lettuce on the baby. It was really hard for me because I was a new mom and I was just like, okay, I just want to do this so fast. I want to do the scene so quickly. And then it was so hard for me as a mom to not really connect with the baby at all and just say like, I need to look up here. Make it look up here. Yes.
然后我把那片巨大的假生菜叶子放在了宝宝身上。这对我来说真的很难，因为我是一个新手妈妈，我当时就想，好吧，我只想快点把这个做完。我想尽快拍完这场戏。然后作为一个妈妈，我很难做到完全不和宝宝产生任何联系，而只是说，我需要看这里。让它看这里。是的。
But it's such a window into Angela, you know, she was a pageant baby. She dresses up her cats. Yes. Her kids are going to be dressed up a lot for all kinds of photos and Andy is on board. I always imagined that Angela dressed Philip in like the little knee socks and shorts and suspenders with the little Peter Pan collar that you always see little Prince George wearing. That's how I imagined Philip dresses. Oh yeah.
但这让我们得以一窥安吉拉的内心，你知道的，她曾是个选美宝宝。她给她的猫打扮。是的。她的孩子们以后也会经常盛装打扮，拍各种各样的照片，而安迪也完全赞同。我总是想象安吉拉把菲利普打扮成那种穿着小中筒袜、短裤、背带裤，还带着那种你总能在小乔治王子身上看到的彼得潘小圆领的衣服。这就是我脑海中菲利普的穿着。哦，是的。
And I also imagined that Angela had like a little sailor suit for him. For sure. Sailor hat. A hundred percent. All of that. Jan comes in as Andy and Angela are having their Aunt Getty's moment creating this baby salad photo and she is not happy. No, she's irritated and she wants to go.
而且我还想象安吉拉为他准备了一套水手服。肯定的。水手帽。百分之百。所有这些。当安迪和安吉拉正在创作这幅婴儿沙拉照片、享受他们的“安吉蒂”时刻时，简走了进来，她可一点也不高兴。不，她很烦躁，她想走了。
She's done. She's done. She finds Michael in the kitchen and she's ready to go and Michael insults Holly again. I guess we've failed to mention that throughout this whole episode, every time Michael, Holly and Jan are together, Michael just keeps, you know, insulting her when Holly was going to go into the conference room. He's like, uh, HR. Now he says she smells like rotten tomatoes and dirt and dirt.
她受够了。她受够了。她在厨房里找到了迈克尔，准备离开了，而迈克尔又一次侮辱了霍莉。我想我们忘了提一件事，在整集节目中，每当迈克尔、霍莉和简聚在一起时，迈克尔总是，你知道的，不断地侮辱她，当霍莉要走进会议室时。他说，呃，人力资源。现在他说她闻起来像烂西红柿和泥土，还有泥土。
She smells like tomatoes and dirt. Yeah. And you know what? Jan sees all of it. Jan knows what Michael's doing and he walks her out to the car and as she's putting the baby in the car seat, she turns around. She's like, there is one more thing you could do for me and he's like, what? And she says, don't date Holly.
她闻起来像西红柿和泥土。是的。你知道吗？简把这一切都看在眼里。简知道迈克尔在做什么，他送她走到车旁，当她把婴儿放进安全座椅时，她转过身来。她说，你还能为我做一件事，他问是什么？她说，不要和霍莉约会。
Yeah. And he's like, why would I hate her? Why would I? You know, and yeah, he clearly likes her. Yeah. Jan leaves. She leaves the stroller that was gifted to her. I know.
是啊。然后他说，我怎么会恨她？我怎么会呢？你知道的，是的，他明显喜欢她。是的。简离开了。她把送给她的婴儿车落下了。我知道。
So tacky. So tacky. Tacky Jan. What was the point of the baby shower that she could get a nap and maybe get some money out of Michael for a college fund? That's what it was. Yeah. Well, Michael is going to go upstairs.
太俗气了。太俗气了。俗气的简。她办婴儿shower的意义何在，就是为了能睡个午觉，也许还能从迈克尔手里弄点钱来做大学基金？就是这样。是的。好吧，迈克尔要上楼了。
When he finds Holly and she says, are you going to still be mean to me? And he just gives her a hug. It's the warmest, most intimate hug. It's so intimate. Amy Ryan is so great. Her eyes just fill with tears. And then Michael has this talking head where he says he didn't feel much when he held Astrid, but he, he got a good feeling when he held Holly.
当他找到霍莉时，她问，你还会对我很坏吗？而他只是给了她一个拥抱。这是最温暖、最亲密的拥抱。太亲密了。艾米·瑞安太棒了。她的眼里充满了泪水。然后迈克尔有了一段独白，他说他在抱阿斯特丽德时没有太多感觉，但是他在抱霍莉时，他有一种很好的感觉。
He asked her out on a date, a real official date. She says, yes, she sure does. So we're ending with a little love connection there, but now Jim and Pam are both trying to call each other at the same time and they miss each other. They both go to voicemail at the same time. And I remember Greg talking to me about this scene. I just loved this idea that we're going to hear each side of their voicemail message and you're going to see they really are connected.
他约她出去约会，一次真正官方的约会。她说，好，她当然同意了。所以我们在那里以一个小小的恋情连接结束了，但现在吉姆和帕姆都在试图同时给对方打电话，结果他们错过了。他们同时转入了语音信箱。我记得格雷格和我谈过这个场景。我太喜欢这个构思了，我们能听到他们各自语音信箱留言的一半，你会发现他们实际上心有灵犀。
They both recall this same story about the time that, you know, some man came into the laundromat and Jim had to save Pam and then they bought a washer dryer. They were calling this same event. And at the end, they both say, I guess this was just one of those days. I miss you. I wish you were home. Yeah. Aaron shared with me that he was just so curious how this scene would turn out because you
他们俩都回忆起同一件事，就是某个男人来到自助洗衣店的那次，吉姆不得不拯救帕姆，然后他们买了一台洗衣机烘干机。他们打给对方是为了同一件事。最后，他们俩都说，我想这就是那种日子之一。我想你。我希望你在家。是的。亚伦跟我分享说，他很好奇这个场景会如何呈现，因为你们
guys filmed it in two different locations. You didn't have the other person there. No, I couldn't hear John. It was like I was really leaving a message. Yeah. And so you guys were just in this vacuum separate. And then in editing, they were going to find the moment and create it. And he just sort of marveled at how the whole thing came together and just so perfectly.
是在两个不同的地点拍摄的。现场没有另一个人。对，我听不到约翰的声音。感觉就像我真的在留言一样。是的。所以你们只是在一个真空里各自独立完成。然后在剪辑中，他们会寻找时机并将之融合。他只是对整件事情是如何完美结合在一起的感到惊叹。
Yes. Well, I had to really imagine in my head as an actor that I was just leaving a message. So in the script, I could see how our dialogue was going to alternate and sync up, but I put that out of my mind and I just did my half without thinking of John's lines in my head at all. Right. And we filmed it like a monologue. Yeah.
是的。嗯，作为演员，我在脑海中必须真正想象我只是在留言。所以在剧本里，我能看出我们的对话将如何交替并同步，但我把那抛在脑后，我只是完成了我的一半，根本没有在脑子里去想约翰的台词。没错。我们就像演独白一样拍了这场戏。是的。
Well, I loved it. I thought it was really sweet. And it also made me a little sad because you can tell the distance is starting to take a toll. Yeah. Well, that ends the episode, but Angela, I just realized I skipped a fan question. Okay. And I don't want to leave Evan L hanging.
好吧，我很喜欢。我觉得真的很甜。这也让我有点难过，因为你能看出距离开始产生影响了。是的。好吧，这集到此结束，不过安吉拉，我刚刚意识到我漏掉了一个粉丝提问。好的。我可不想冷落了埃文·L。
Okay. Evan. Evan wrote in to say at 17 minutes, 30 seconds, was that really rain driving around with the stroller tied to the back of the car or was that a stunt driver? Well, we had a stunt driver. His name was Sean Crowder. We also had a stunt coordinator named Wally Crowder. And so Sean did the driving parts.
好的。埃文。埃文来信说，在17分30秒时，真的是雷恩开车带着系在车后面的婴儿车吗，还是特技演员开的？嗯，我们有个特技演员。他叫肖恩·克劳德。我们还有一个特技统筹叫沃利·克劳德。所以肖恩负责驾驶的部分。
Mm hmm. And there were some shots of rain inside the car, but the other stuff, that was a stunt driver. Yes. We would often do the driving that was just sort of like where you pull up and stop. Yeah. But then if there was like aggressive driving, that's when the stunt driver would take over. Yes.
嗯哼。有些雷恩在车内的镜头，但其他部分，那是特技演员。是的。我们通常会拍那些只是把车开过来然后停下的驾驶镜头。是的。但如果有那种激进驾驶，那就是特技演员接管的时候了。是的。
Well, I loved this episode. I thought it was so good and layered with so much heartfelt stuff. And before we say goodbye, I have a little bit of trivia for you. Okay. Moving to babycenter.com, here are the top girl and boy names in 2008. Oh, from when we did this episode. That's right. Any guesses for the girl?
嗯，我很喜欢这集。我觉得非常棒，而且充满了许多走心的细节。在我们说再见之前，我有一点冷知识要分享。好的。转到 babycenter.com，以下是2008年最受欢迎的女孩和男孩名字。噢，就是我们拍这集的时候。没错。猜猜女孩的名字是什么？
Emma. Yes. Ah! You got it. I was thinking maybe because of the friend's baby. Yes. Rachel had Emma really put that name on the map. Guess what the boy name was.
艾玛。是的。啊！被你猜中了。我在想也许是因为《老友记》里的宝宝。是的。瑞秋生了艾玛，确实让这个名字名声大噪。猜猜男孩的名字是什么。
I guessed Emma for the girl like you, but I did not guess right for the boy name. Liam. Aiden. Aiden. Aiden was the top boy name. Was that from Sex and the City? I don't know. I guessed Jack.
我和你一样猜女孩名字是艾玛，但我没猜对男孩的名字。利亚姆。艾登。艾登。艾登是排名第一的男孩名字。那是来自《欲望都市》吗？我不知道。我猜的是杰克。
Okay. He was in the top five, but Aiden and Emma. Well there it is. You've learned some new baby showers, the sip and see. Eminems are still printing names. Yeah. And the orbit stroller is actually really good. And Emma and Aiden, 2008 babies, where are you now?
好吧。他排在前五名，不过是艾登和艾玛。就是这样。你们了解了一些新的婴儿派对习俗，比如看宝宝派对（sip and see）。阿姆面条（M&Ms）还在印名字呢。是的。Orbit婴儿车其实真的很好。艾玛和艾登，2008年的宝宝们，你们现在在哪里？
I would love it if an Emma and Aiden got married. Oh, well that was baby shower. We'll see you next week. Bye you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins.
如果一个叫艾玛的人和一个叫艾登的人结婚了，我可太乐意看到了。好了，这就是婴儿派对。我们下周见。拜拜，伙计们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。
Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音响工程师是山姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科伊。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的 Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。